herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
ich bin wieder zu hause in köln und
hinter der kamera ist trotzdem noch wir
machen nämlich heute ein video bei dem
ich das in meiner zuschauer und
zuschauerinnen erraten muss die idee
habe ich von tahir und der tb von alex v
glaube ich und er hat die idee aus
amerika sozusagen bin ich ganz unten an
der kette der ideenklau aber die video
die tropfen lustig geht würde ich sagen
einfach los und bitte zeig mir doch mal
das aller erste foto von einem zuschauer
er ist echt insofern weil ich habe
absolut keine ahnung ob ich gut
einschätzen kann ist das ein ganz großer
zuschauer der ist nicht so ein richtiger
stalker ich werde das jetzt mal das bild
ein komisch sieht er aus 5 richtig es
richtig fünf einzel geholfen
die leute sind daher für lukas
friedlichen halbe million geschätzt
nächste peter brings stammgebieten
mobile einzuschicken wenn die leute auch
wirklich damit einverstanden sind dass
sie sie verwende auf dem mond sei
einfach nicht zu allen die gezeigt sind
und ja machen wir weiter ein paar 2 ok
[Musik]
vor die wut auf jeden fall schon älter
aus ich würde sagen
[Musik]
17.22 wirklich okay sorry sieht als
kompliment 22 hätte ich nicht gedacht
aber cool cooler auf 20 jähriger in
einer community auf ok dann machen wir
mal weiter bisher lag ich bei luca
einmal fast richtig und bei ihr leider
nicht okay als nächstes haben wir werden
oder geht von beide war es okay damit
ich mir erstmal ganz kurz also jetzt der
beste im alter schätzen
ich klage
[Musik]
16 und 17 oder 16 16 beide 16 33 häufig
schlecht bin ich da drin aber ich sehe
auch echt älter aus essen sind schreibt
mir gerne auch mal die kommentare was
ihr so geraten hatten was ihr dach wäre
die als ist weil bin ich wirklich so
schlecht
liga haben wir weiter heute bock drauf
habe kann ich es auch gerne mal als
challenge machen also zb gegen lukas
bafin oder sonstwie und derjenige der
schlächter ist darin muss dann irgendwie
mit strafe machen oder so kennt ja den
youtube doch wenn er zwanzig kommt wäre
das auch okay nächste person
ok ich lebe sehr weit aus dem fenster
und sagen sie's nicht 22 okay man hinter
der kamera nicht schon zustimmt ich will
immer als allererstes irgendwie so 16
sagen ich weiß es aber ich sage ich sage
es 15 8
ich bin echt schlecht da drin also bist
du noch mal es sollte ich wirklich keine
eingriffe führen dadurch dass ich leute
im fall schaeffler
ich bin nur einfach echt schlecht darin
allein von einem foto sowas sagen doch
recht schwierig also wenn man sich mit
leuten unterhält oder sowas kann man
denken wissen wie alt die leute sind
aber so bin ich nicht so gut ok-chef
peter sind ja auch noch mal ungefähr wer
immer die haut weiter machen und damit
auch die gesichter verformen 15
verachtete nimmst du nur die ältesten
warum promi zu beraten
ok also raus hat anscheinend externen
genau ist auch richtig gemein weil ich
hab halt so im kopf hatten einen
community so großen teil auch unter 18
ist und er nimmt aber nur 48 bin oder
drüber sind jetzt zeig mal wobei die
jungs waren natürlich junger die waren
jünger von jesus jesus wenn du dich
deine jüngeren hier komm gib mir noch
mehr snapshot wird er etwa einfach ist
dieser aber es gab leute ich habe recht
gehabt wirklich jetzt anscheinend habe
ich schon wieder raus es war das
allererste mal dass ich was richtig hat
wir im gesamten video bisher
pauli ich war nicht immer so knapp neben
waren so sollten eigentlich immer
mindestens drei jahre entfernt wenn
nicht bald was nicht sagt ok 15 414 dass
es zähle also ein jahr kann man aber
nicht vertritt ja auch meistens doch
kann gut sein
wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich wird sie
morgen 15 und ich hab eigentlich nur
einen tag im voraus gelacht die leute so
ist das manchmal 14
okay immerhin immerhin leute
12 14
ist so schwer zu schätzen teilweise sagt
mal kurz hätte zu das alter richtig
geschätzt vorläufige auch falsch mehr
er legt aber natürlich seine stirn in
falten was ist eigentlich unmöglich
macht weiter richtig vorausgesagt hat er
dadurch freie zeiten machen einen etwa
ich sage 15 immer die 15 14 immer ein
jahren eben verdammt verdammt
okay das echt schwierig also da sind
diese luftballons im weg mehr da kann
man überhaupt nichts sehen wir als sie
eigentlich ist
eine konische form an die beförderung
ich würde aber sagen sie
wir hatten ja viel kraft
die linzer övp ich habe sowieso ein
gefühl übrigens leute wo wir gerade beim
zuschauen sind in weniger als zwei
wochen ist schon die sevenone kommen in
wien das nicht mehr habe ich weniger als
ein großes youtube treffen das sind
unter anderem luca ich was sind glaube
ich nicht aber auf jeden fall noch viele
andere youtuber von unserem netzwerk und
ihr könnt da hinkommen
es ist wirklich günstig also da macht
niemand gewinnen oder sowas dann es
einfach echt coole möglichkeit von
unserem netzwerk dass ihr euch zuschauer
treffen können und es heißt in den raum
und einen rahmen dafür gibt und wenn wir
dahin kommen wollte ich euch jetzt mal
hier den code 15 euro sparen können und
das ist mein coach und kommt dahin
bittet rampage ii extreme vielfach
nächste foto 13
ich würde sagen zum abschluss machen
wieso man schnelldurchlauf das heißt wir
nehmen drei zuschauer und ich nehm ich
schnell ihr alter zu erraten ohne groß
nachzudenken wenn ihr richtig haben alle
richtig habe dann
dringlich in zwei wochen wieder bittet
alle luftig 14
nein vielleicht meist weiter welches ich
gleich mal ran 15 16 leute insgesamt
zwei leute richtig gab 3 war okay dann
drei läufer also genau ist ja und mein
fahrrad ernährerin schreibt mir wirklich
gerne in die kommentare was ihr geraten
nach dafür auch dass die leute so alles
sind oder seit ihr einfach gut und ich
bin schlecht das war dann von heute
sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder für
sie wollen kommt ihr wüsstet und